[Music]
welcome it's the you know never find me
what the hell is that I am the ghost no
do this oh why what's going on here
let's go away
[Laughter]
she thinks that's not gonna work this
time we were shooting an object they
were just so bad yeah I know but I've
got stuck on you like I was walking over
you or something I wasn't me I was
behind the chest of drawers like
embedded in the wall oh oh [ __ ] I'm
stuck help help help help me specific
via South waters come back doing days
always upstairs I'm kind of really cool
prom where's it stay stay stay
no I'm not no I'm not no oh my god this
is this is Larry's bluffing is the
[ __ ] bluffing us come back they fell
for it
we failed so bad that's me
all right you guys down there oh [ __ ] no
listen to me she says that every one
little piggy don't tell me what to do
let's go find these [ __ ] I'm at it
wait go this way you're at it did you
say no ah
barrel does suspicious watermelon hiding
okay everyone be quiet
imagine yourself as the Prophet so why
are there four boxes I recall there
being three well that's the way I want
to go on with my day
stupid bugs trying to get away
well what's going on I don't know you
guys just started screaming really
loudly
so whose debt just matters I mean yeah I
was spared or am i hmm
oh wait you're much interest [ __ ] Oh poo
gee did you like that Tommy hey that
watermelon looks pretty tasty don't you
dig
um yeah I think I think you should
because even the peas is there you
didn't see you last time so you pretty
why not to see this time no no this this
this okay and then following writers
hunters are you ready to be the best
darn hunters you've ever been in your
life brother Dylan is you're like okay
okay that's how Sorry Sorry
Jan I need a favor bit I think I'm
suspicious looking am I
now you're fine just don't do anything
there's so many blocks here I think it's
this chair
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh my god this barrel what do you have
to say for yourself me know you getting
hotter
no you getting hotter okay no I reckon
they're not in the main room [ __ ]
watch supersonic speed oh wait I'm stuck
on your mags I'm stuck on you can you
move okay let's go keep going that
cinder block though to the right in
there all right let's go any ball damn
it okay okay let's see let's see yeah I
have very well I have always been very
fond of varying boxes I can tell you're
gonna be good thing I had this crowbar
in the box
why oh wait don't go in the bedroom
what man I will just make a noise he's
not a boy
what the [ __ ] I am the body very good at
bluffing like me
I just burn a tit OPA Oh what they
destroyed it wait a second
what don't you dare touch that bite I
just want to go on a bike ride
ah this is so nice only I could drive
you away if only I could kill it was it
her I froze I'll be enjoyed another
episode of profit leave a like if you
did it helps me out a lot and let me
know if you want more I'll be happy to
give it to you and not the way that it
sounded like anyways how's it brother
[Music]